What do you think, Dana?
Oh my gosh.
I'm kind of feeling a little nauseous.
I feel nauseous, too.
That was a little stressful.
We just met with the owner.
He's super nice.
He's really, really nice.
He showed us all around the car and stuff.
We were kind of newbies and didn't get all the money out that we needed to...
...because we thought we could just transfer it.
But then in Germany, they would only allow us to transfer 2,500 a time,...
...and it was already Saturday and so then it wouldn't go through till Monday.
So, he was obviously not gonna give you the car...
...until the money is in our bank account.
My bad.
Yeah, we're still learning but that just means that we stay one more night in Munster...
...and then, hopefully, we can get the money out tomorrow.
Oh, look at this.
So, this is our new van.
This is our home.
So, they have it set up that you sleep here and this goes like this,...
...and you can sleep like this, or you make it a couch like that, look.
We bought a van.
Maybe.
Well, technically, it's still not ours, but,...
...tomorrow.